are you doing today sir
good seeing you long time no see what's
on your shirt
uh it's a little schwarzenegger from
total recall got it
nice good seeing you how are you i'm
sorry you're not in this empty chair in
front of me i'm doing very well i hope
you and your family are also doing
extremely well and i like you thanos and
i like your ed209 yeah was shanxi dusted
in the blip i don't want to answer that
question because i want people to see
the movie this movie has one of my
deepest cut blip references easter eggs
in it and i don't know if you've you
noticed it or not but i love it
and it is obscure and i want to see if
we can bring it into other movies um but
let's let people see the movie and
decide
i need to watch it when i watch it again
i now will be looking closer it's a good
one it's purely i'll give you a hint
it's purely visual it's not it's not a
it's not a dialogue reference it's a
visual reference
got it um did you guys consider
uh using chung chi in the way black
panther was introduced into the mcu as
like a supporting character in a
previous movie or was it always the
intention of introducing him solo movie
this is where you're gonna get them
solo movie was always the intention now
that doesn't mean the intentions don't
change sometimes as they did with with
black panther when we when we decided to
make civil war um
but in this case it was always it was
always shangshi because as as you see
the movie um what we love about it is
not just
uh the individual character of shanxi
but the world that he is from and the
family sort of shakespearean element of
his entire uh family history do you guys
envision chung chi as a trilogy we
always make a movie with the intention
of trying to make it well enough that
people are very interested to see more
stories and if they are then we then we
we'll tell more
got it so you're not gonna you're not
gonna answer this one
no i just did what are you talking about
but you know what i mean like i would
love to know if like uh anyway you did
but i
anyway i was hoping you'd uh who wins in
a fight between chung chi and thor or
shang chi
and hulk
i'm just curious about his power level
as compared to some of the other mcu
characters well
i think they're i think you know
who wins in a in a fight tony stark or
hulk well
is tony stark wearing a suit or is he
not in the suit um
i think there are various power levels
that you see in this movie of chongqi um
at his most powerful
he's
strong she's pretty darn powerful uh but
so is the hulk
so
you know what's the most disappointing
answer it would be a draw
that's your worst answer they used to do
that in the comics with team ups
remember that and then it'll be a draw
and you'd go i don't like that yeah i
know uh but i'm very happy that what if
by the way is on the air i just have to
say that oh thank you um
do you think that when do you think we
might be getting another avengers type
movie do you think it's like four years
away
five years more we want there to be a
reasonable amount of time
from the end game to to start uh to
start our a new saga which is already
underway and already started um and then
you need some time as we did in phase
one to build that saga before you start
uh start um bringing everybody together
every day i see on twitter people
wondering when are when is the spiderman
trailer gonna drop so i'll ask you when
do you think the spider-man and the
doctor strange two trailers when do you
think they might drop
uh they will both be coming out before
the movie comes out we'll have the
trailer come out first and then before
the movies if you look at the release
date for the movies you go we'll
definitely be before that great got it
okay good
got it um i am curious uh what is the
status of your script the star wars
script with michael uh let me ask that
uh in in the works
improv
is it uh do you envision that can i ask
is that a can you at least say is it a
solo movie or is it one of these things
that could be a movie and a disney plus
thing it is not about han solo han solo
is not in it no
got it well now that it's come out that
anthony is returning for captain america
four do you already have a release date
in mind
yes i mean we always we always uh work
towards release dates it doesn't mean
they don't shift and change
certainly as we've seen
lately um but uh but we have we we have
something specific in mind yes do you
think it could be filming next year
uh
i forgot to bring the schedule steve i'm
sorry
got it um marvel used to announce
evade uh marvel used to announce the
start of productions and i'm very
curious you guys still haven't announced
like your black panther 2
cast or the some of the key
uh people that are working on it whether
it be director photography or some of
the other crew um is that something that
you guys have pushed like is there a
reason you're not doing these sort of
start of production announcements or
it's just i'm just curious
uh that's a good question
and i don't know i
now that you mentioned i do recall we
used to do that i think we used to do
that to sort of get ahead of of uh
any leaks or or
set photos that could be leaked things
like that i think we now realize you
know people are gonna get pictures of
whatever they wanna get pictures of uh
uh if you're out in public um but it's a
good question we should we could look
into that just for you steve especially
with ed 209 pointing guns in my face
behind exactly
i am very excited about loki getting a
season two on disney plus um uh do you
know
do you envision that filming next year
and you currently are you talking to
people about who might be directing and
writing the series uh it is it is uh it
is underway we're developing it as we
speak uh the hope is that much of the
same team uh will return kate uh is uh
is going on to bigger and better things
uh uh so the director search will begin
shortly and i'm not being invasive uh
i'm i we have a start date i'm not sure
exactly uh where it falls uh between uh
next year or the year after when will we
be announcing young avengers
when will we be announcing anything in
this world uh uh is we'll have to figure
we'll have to figure out we just
announced release date for the hawkeye
series um
so announcements you know we announced a
lot of stuff last time we were on that
stage in hall h at san diego comic con
and now we still have to make good on on
many of the things we've announced then
do you think that marble will be going
to more non-earth planets after
guardians of the galaxy iii
yes
anything you want to tease more than
that
uh no but i think i think it was always
something that we were very um anxious
to do to be able to tell stories
throughout the entire it is called the
universe after all um and and i think
audiences now are very comfortable um uh
going
to uh to strange planets with us so we
we certainly will continue to do that
before uh before guardians three and
after guardians three
uh in the uh the ten rings will return
do you envision this as a disney plus
thing or is this more of a movie
uh it could be any or both you never
know when the ten rings could could show
up the thing about shanghai is that the
third act could
take place in almost a miyazaki movie it
is really pushing
where the mcu is um uh i love stuff like
this it it just expands the universe but
was there any concern that maybe this is
almost too much for some people that
it's you know or do you think that after
having a talking raccoon the audience is
ready for everything well i think it's
all in the execution i don't know that
any anything is too uh is too far we
certainly never looked at it like that
there are other planets uh within the
marvel universe as you mentioned there
are other realities there are other
universes there are other dimensions and
uh and i see no reason not to not to uh
explore them all if they can be part and
parcel of an emotional story connected
to character and certainly talo in the
third act of shangxi is exactly that um
and i don't think it's too much the only
thing that surprised me in early
reactions and i don't know if this has
been online but it was in some of the
early
a lot of the reference points
some people think there are a couple of
pokemon characters in there they're not
pokemon characters but they look like
this they are inspired by similar things
i guess which which which took me by
surprise
i'm out of time but could i just ask you
one other thing yeah
uh i am curious you you obviously early
rough cuts of all the movies obviously
and i'm just curious with the upcoming
movies like you know tyka's thor sequel
how does that movie when you see a rough
cut of that compared to the last one you
know what i mean like in terms of i mean
how does it compare and what was your
reaction after watching it it's very
difficult to to compare any first cut to
a final cut we usually compare them to
other first cuts we've seen
um
and everything is always rough uh and
everything is by the way i'm not even
admitting i've seen the rough cut of
love and thunder yet but in general you
look for the promise that that can be
fulfilled and we've been very lucky that
that all of our rough cuts no matter how
rough um hold hold great promise
i would be shocked if you have not seen
many different things um anyway i
appreciate you giving me your time and i
hope chung chi is a huge huge hit all
right good seeing you steve thank you